[MUSIC PLAYING]
CAROL FULP: Our organization
is a diversity consulting
organization.
And over the years,
we have actually
provided leadership development
for 4,000 executives
and professionals of color.
It's been a journey for me
being at the partnership.
What led me to the
partnership was really
when President
Obama appointed me
to be the US representative
to the United Nations
for the 65th General Assembly.
And it was a really
humbling experience.
Each year, the president
has the opportunity
to appoint someone outside
of the State Department
to be a part of the delegation.
And this was a role that Eleanor
Roosevelt filled, Coretta Scott
King filled, and then I had
the opportunity to fill.
So you can imagine how
humbling this experience was.
And when you stand up on the
stage of the United Nations,
at that iconic podium,
and you look out
amongst the sea
of ambassadors, it
hits you that the
world is primarily
black and brown and yellow by
the ambassadors that you see.
And so when I came
back to Boston,
I wanted to help Boston to be
more reflective of the United
Nations.
And so I left my
job at John Hancock
and took on this role at
the partnership as CEO
in order to help companies
advance in diversity.
And so that's what I've been
doing these last six years.
And that's what led me to write
"Success through Diversity."
Now, we were talking earlier.
And while I might be
passionate about diversity,
I only want to
approach diversity
from a business perspective.
I don't want to approach
it from my passion.
I want to approach it from,
why is it good for business?
And so thus the tagline, why
the most inclusive companies
will win.
Because it's about winning.
So let me share
with you this story.
"Toy giant Mattel
is another example
of a company that catapulted
its business forward
by appealing to a
diverse marketplace.
For decades, since its debut
in 1959, the Barbie doll--
flawlessly thin, high
heeled, and white skinned--
was a cultural sensation, and
one of the world's best selling
toys.
Over the years, Mattel
modestly diversified
the toy's occupations
and ethnicities,
creating a Barbie business
woman, 1963, a Barbie
astronaut, 1965, an
African-American Barbie, '67,
and a Barbie surgeon, '73.
Mattel's efforts
enabled the doll
to maintain about a 90% market
share in girl-oriented toys
for most of the 20th century.
By the mid 2000s, Barbie's
dominance and brand appeal
began to lag.
After four straight quarters
of plummeting sales,
it was no longer the
best selling doll.
The brand was losing
relevance, said
Lisa McKnight, senior
vice president at Mattel.
We knew we had to
change the conversation.
A creative team
within Mattel worked
for two years under the
secretive code, Project Dawn,
began Barbie's modern makeover,
designing a more inclusive set
of dolls that more
accurately reflected
the size and complexion
of America's children.
In 2015, Mattel unleashed
the fruits of Project Dawn,
launching a new generation of
dolls, complete with curvy body
sizes, 23 hair colors, 22
hairdos, 18 eye colors,
and an array of skin tones.
This product launch, Mattel's
most significant rebranding
effort to date, has proven
revitalizing and lucrative.
Parents and children
alike flocked
to the ethnically, racially, and
bodily diverse product lines.
Barbie became the most
diverse doll product line
and at the Toy Industry
Association's annual Toy
of the Year awards
in 2017, the company
won the coveted Doll
of the Year Award.
This new generation
of Barbies wouldn't
have been possible without
a diverse workforce
inside Mattel.
To help design a culturally
sensitive and compelling
black Barbie, for
example, the company's
marketing teams
consulted with Mattel's
African-American
forum, the toy maker's
employee resource group.
Members helped get the doll's
names, skin tone, and hair
just right.
They asked us very
candid questions
about the look of the doll.
Did they get the
skin tone right?
What about the nose?
And the hair, said
David Simmons,
associate manager
of account planning
and a member of the ERG group.
This was important,
because consumers roundly
criticized the 1967
African-American
Barbie, Colored Francie,
for her inauthenticity.
Besides having a
darker skin tone,
she lacked any bodily
features or hairstyles
typical of African-Americans.
As African-American Tom
Burrell, a diversity advertising
trailblazer famously
quipped, black people are not
dark-skinned white people.
A lack of authenticity plagued
previous Barbie diversity
efforts as well.
With the wheelchair-bound
Share a Smile Becky doll, 1997,
lacking the correct proportions
to fit into her dream house
elevator and the
computer engineer
Barbie product
line requiring help
from boys to actually code.
However, for its 2016
line of gamer Barbies,
Mattel drew on female
engineer leaders,
such as Molly Proffitt, CEO
of Ker-Chunk Games, Julie Ann
Crommett, entertainment industry
editor in chief at Google,
and Kimberly Bryant,
founder of Black Girls Code,
to help design a compelling
doll that resembled a real tech
geek.
These women advised Mattel
during their design process,
ensuring the new
career game developer
Barbie was authentic,
compelling, and would help
inspire a new generation
of budding female computer
scientists and STEM leaders.
The computer has
JavaScript on it,
and you can see various
instances of game engines
on her laptop, said
one of the leaders,
commenting on the new line.
I really know the girls need
an icon that shows them they
can be part of the tech space.
And Barbie does that.
She has the power
to tell girls they
can be makers and builders.
Even Barbie's companion, Ken,
received a totally diversity
makeover in 2017.
Prior to the new
iteration of Ken dolls,
Barbie's plastic beau typically
sported blonde hair, blue eyes,
and a chiseled figure.
Revamped Ken comes, in
one case, with a man bun,
while another sports a dad bod,
a Fortune article observed.
All of this increased
diversity has
led to more prosperity
for the company.
Mattel's brunette Latina Barbie
with curves and brown eyes
became the company's 2016 best
seller, a feat the Huntington
Post senior reporter Emily
Peck calls, a clear victory
for the toy maker giant.
Following four years of
declines, sales of the dolls
increased 7% in 2016,
earning nearly $1 billion
for the company, certainly
proving that diversity sells."
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
CAROL FULP: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Well, I'm so glad
that you showed that excerpt,
because it really leads
into the first question
that I wanted to ask you.
And that is, as a woman of color
writing a book about diversity,
you took the lives of not moral
compass leading or anything
that would say, as a human
being, this makes sense,
but you instead went the
route of really highlighting
why, as a business, like
you said about the tagline,
why it'll make you win or
why it is a business case.
Can you speak to why
you went that route
when writing the book?
CAROL FULP: Because at the end
of the day, we are in business.
And at the end of the
day, we want to win.
And we have to approach
things from the bottom line.
And so when we
look at diversity,
we want to look at the
changing landscape.
It's important for
us to understand
this changing demographic
shift we're experiencing.
Today, there are
more babies of color
born in this country
than Caucasian babies.
Today, there are more students
of color in this country
than Caucasians.
In 2042, the Census
Bureau indicates
that there will be more
people of color in America
than Caucasians.
That's our workforce.
That's our marketplace.
And so in order for us to
produce goods and services
for our marketplace and for
our global marketplace--
I talked about the UN--
we need to have individuals
in our companies
that are reflective
of our marketplace.
And so it only stands
to reason that we want
to have a diverse workforce.
And then you look
at all the studies.
You look at the
McKinsey studies that
indicates the more
diverse workforces are
the more profitable
workforces, because again,
at the end of the day, you
want diversity of thought.
And the best way to get
diversity of thought
is to have people not only
with different experiences,
but different cultures
and who can add
a different lens to a problem.
And so diversity is critical.
There's a new
study that came out
that said that the more
innovative companies,
the companies that
are more diverse,
are the more
innovative companies.
The more innovative companies
are producing more patents.
And when they did the studies,
those innovative companies
were the diverse companies.
The more diverse
companies produce
more innovative companies,
the more patents,
they receive more patents.
SPEAKER 1: I definitely
can believe that.
And I'm sure you know Google's
goal is to be among the most
innovative of companies--
CAROL FULP: Oh, absolutely.
SPEAKER 1: To be on
the cutting edge.
So then the next
question I have for you
stems off of that same thought.
I know there are some folks
in the room that are actually
on our recruiting
teams, but a lot
of this office in
particular don't really
have a touch point with our
recruiting or hiring and HR
teams, heavily engineering.
How would you say, for those
who are interested in kind
of seeing the needle move here
but don't really work in a role
where they can directly hire,
let's say, more diverse talent
to get us that innovation
that you were speaking about,
how can we still kind of
show our passion for this
or try to make some
progress on the topic,
although it's not necessarily
a part of our core roles
here at Google?
CAROL FULP: It is a
part of your core roles.
And it's important for
you to understand how much
influence millennials have.
Today, there are more
millennials than baby boomers.
And corporate understands that
millennials are our leaders
and our future leaders.
And your voice is
incredibly powerful.
And corporate and
executives understand
that millennials think
differently and understand
that you have a lot of options.
And they understand that
you care deeply about values
and that a company has to
have ethics and values.
And if you say
this is important,
it becomes important
to the company.
I can give you an example.
Charlottesville occurred.
And there were a number of
companies where the CEO wrote
a letter to their employee
population saying,
this is not who we are.
We condemn this.
And as recently as
six months ago, I
was speaking to a HR
executive here in Boston
and they said to
me, we still are
feeling the effects of not
coming out and saying something
at Charlottesville.
And so your voice is important.
And so employees, if diversity
is important to you--
and it is.
Millennials are far more
diverse than baby boomers.
It's what you know.
You don't want to be living
or working in a society
where there is just
one of any kind.
You value diversity.
You are really stimulated by it.
And so if you say this is
important for your growth
and development, your
executive management
will respond to that.
And so I would say
give voice to this
and say it is important for
you and that it is something
you are willing to step up
and help take responsibility
for and help be on teams to
help increase the diversity
of your organization.
SPEAKER 1: We can
accept that charge.
That's a really good idea.
I know that one
reason, a lot of times,
we see that women
of color or women
in general or any
underrepresented minority
maybe is not seen progressing
through corporate America
as quickly is due to unconscious
biases that we may hold.
And Google has, like I
think many companies,
we have an unconscious
bias training
that all employees have to take.
But I know that you've
actually spoken out,
saying that you
don't necessarily
believe in having a mandatory
unconscious bias training.
Can you speak to why that is
and what might work better?
CAROL FULP: Well,
I don't personally
want to go to a class
called unconscious bias.
I think that the
term makes you feel--
it puts you-- it
makes you tense.
And so I do want to
go to a forum, a class
on leading for the future.
And that's what we call our
forums at the partnership,
leading for the future.
And so we talk about,
what does that look like?
What does the
population look like?
What are the technologies
going to look like?
There is so much change.
And because there
is so much change,
what would get in the way
of us accepting this change?
And so we begin to peel
back the onion that way.
And that's how we get
at unconscious bias.
But I find uncomfortable going
to a session called unconscious
bias.
I'd much rather go to a session
called leading for the future,
because all of us want
to be good leaders.
And then we find
out, OK, well, what
might get in the way of
us being a good leader?
And something that gets in the
way of us being a good leader
is this unconscious
bias, which we all have.
And one of the things
that I always do is,
in this leading for
the future forum,
is I tell people of my bias.
When I walked into
the partnership,
the partnership had all women.
And I love being a woman.
And so the personal side of me
was most comfortable with that.
But I also knew that I
was missing something
from an organizational
standpoint.
And so my first
few hires were men.
And my culture shifted
in the organization.
It expanded.
We had perspectives
that were not there.
And so my organization
was better
because we opened
up the organization
so that it was more diverse.
And while we're an
organization that
focuses on ethnic diversity,
we have individuals
who are white who work
in our organization,
because I don't want to
have one of any kind.
I want our organization to
be reflective of the world,
to be reflective
of organizations,
and we are going
to build together.
So unconscious bias--
first, let's think about
why and who we are and
what our own biases are.
And let's check them
at the door before we
come into the organization.
SPEAKER 1: I love that.
You should teach our
unconscious bias training
and we can change the name
and you can tell us that.
That was really thoughtful.
Thank you for sharing that.
I know that you were
speaking about your goals
for the partnership
and your employees
and what you would like
to see reflected there.
We, as a company--
and I'm sure many
companies-- are also
trying to diversify the pipeline
and make sure that we've
got talent coming in.
But a lot of times, folks say,
well, there's just not there.
We're looking for this
role and we're not
seeing a lot of minority
groups represented
for this specific role or job.
What do you say to that?
And how would you
challenge folks to resolve
that issue for their company?
CAROL FULP: Well, first
of all, let me tell you
that I don't use the word
minority, because in the world,
people of color are
not the minority.
In Boston, people of color
are 54% of the population.
So we're not the minority.
So I call us people of
color rather than minority.
And the word minority has a
certain connotation as well.
So I use the word
people of color.
So I encourage people
to do that as well.
And I encourage people to
move beyond the traditional
recruiting sources.
We have 4,000
individuals who have
been through the partnership
training programs.
Next month, Carmen will
be training over 250,
I think you have starting.
There are people who are
in our greater Boston area.
You have to look beyond
the traditional sources.
You went to Howard University.
There is a Howard University
alumni chapter here in Boston.
That's a great place to start.
Here at the partnership,
we've created a job board
for companies who want
to be able to advertise
their jobs through us, because
individuals know that people
who are advertising on the
partnership's job board website
really value diversity.
So there are ways that
you can approach and find
and resource people of color.
One of the strategies
that I mention in the book
is the Rooney rule.
And that is to say that
when you have a job
open to ensure that you
interview diverse talent.
You don't fill that job unless
you have a diverse pool.
Now, we're not telling you
to hire a diverse talent.
But we're telling you to make
sure that the pool is diverse.
And this rule
comes from the NFL,
when they tried to
increase diversity
amongst their coaches.
And it just so happened
that they were at its peak
when, one Super Bowl, they had
two African-Americans playing
against each other, two coaches.
But for a long time,
there was no coaches
who were African-American.
Now, we still have
a long way to go.
And we still have a long
way to go with the NFL.
But the Rooney rule is
really an opportunity for us
to ensure our pools are diverse.
Managers can select whomever,
but at least we're seeing,
we're being intentional about
seeing candidates of color.
SPEAKER 1: That
makes a lot of sense.
I know that there are some folks
in the audience who might also
have questions.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
The excerpt was excellent.
I'm really excited
to read the rest.
CAROL FULP: Well, thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I
was wondering, what
were some of the biggest
challenges for you
in writing this book?
CAROL FULP: Oh, that's
a great question.
Well, I think the some
of the biggest challenges
were finding companies
that had really excelled
and were exceptional.
And I was able to find
Hallmark Health, who
had used the Rooney rule and
seen their profits go up.
So it's one thing to
use the Rooney rule,
but I wanted to be able to
relate that to profitability.
And so when
interviewing their CEO,
they attributed that
to their profitability.
So I was glad to see that.
And then the other
challenge was to be
able to find CEOs who
would be able to indicate
what they did wrong.
And none of us want to
indicate what we did wrong.
And so those were the
biggest challenges.
But that's a great question.
So thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
Thanks for coming today.
CAROL FULP: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I was curious, as
you were doing your research,
was there a certain industry
that excels in this area?
And if they do
excel in this area,
are they as equally successful
in retention as well
as recruiting?
Are there things
that we can learn
from other industries that might
be doing it better than ours?
And along those
lines, if they are
successful in their
recruiting methods,
is there something they partner
with retention methods as well
that helps them be successful?
CAROL FULP: Yeah, I found
that the finance industry
is particularly good
at it, because they've
been doing it a longer
period of time, number one.
And recruiting is certainly
linked to retention.
And there's one finance
company that has
27 ERGs in their organizations.
Do you know what ERGs are?
Employee resource groups.
27.
So they have a resource
group for every difference.
So people feel valued
there and that they can--
their difference is valued.
It's supported by their company,
and that they think twice
about leaving, because
ERGs are really
a core part of the business.
The other thing that I found
is that ERGs are merging,
are moving towards
business resource groups.
So the Mattel story--
so it's just not an
ERG now, that companies
are using the ERGs as
business resource groups.
And they are being
valued even more
and being brought
into the business.
And that's really
helpful for employees.
And it's helpful for
companies as well.
Great questions.
AUDIENCE: I actually
have one more question.
CAROL FULP: Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Do you find that
there's any particular--
whether it be finance or another
industry or company that's
really skilled at upward
mobility for people of color?
It's something we talk
about all the time.
I sit on the university
programs team
and we do university
recruiting and so forth.
And we control so much of the
students' experience on campus.
And we want to make sure
that we want to set them up
for success wherever they go.
So whether they end up at Google
or they end up somewhere else,
we want make sure they're
having a good experience
and that when they get there,
they can really flourish.
So there's a lot of
companies, I can imagine,
that do pretty well
recruiting and retaining,
but don't necessarily
see people of color
moving up at the same
rate as other folks.
Are there any companies
that you notice
through your research
that are really
good at promoting upward
mobility for people of color?
CAROL FULP: The
company in Boston
that I think does it
best is Eastern Bank.
And that's because of
the executive leadership
of that company.
So Bob Rivers is
the chairman and CEO
and is actually named
after Robert Kennedy,
and so takes the issue of
diversity and inclusion
very personally and
chose specifically,
when expanding the
business, chose
to expand in areas like
Lawrence and Lowell
and was able to
make the business
case for moving into those
socioeconomic depressed areas
and build those
areas and make money.
In that company, the
chair of the board
is an African-American
woman and she
succeeded an African-American
male chair, Bob's successor,
the vice chair of the
board and president,
is an African-American male.
When he started, 90% of
the board was white male.
And now, 50% of the board
are women, people of color,
or LGBT.
And that attracts a
whole set of people
who want to be able
to work for a company,
because the culture has shifted.
So at the end of the day, what
is happening with diversity?
It's all about culture.
And you have to create a culture
where difference is valued,
where difference
is not tolerated,
where your difference
is an asset, where
your difference
is valued and can
be seen as a business value.
And that is why
people will stay.
And so when you're bringing
in these students--
and if you don't have it, if
you don't have it all together,
you ask them for their help.
You say, here's
where we want to be.
And we're not here yet.
But we need your help.
And help us get there.
Empower them to help
shape your culture.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
It sounds like the book
and a lot of your work
is in the business context.
I'm definitely super
interested in reading it.
I'm curious, though,
to what degree
you've run into similar
issues in other domains,
like politics, for
example, if you
have any stories
or research that
might not be
included in the book
that you could share about that?
CAROL FULP: In terms of?
AUDIENCE: In terms of the
value of diversity and the way
it can benefit countries
or political systems,
in addition to businesses.
CAROL FULP: Oh, well,
yeah, that's who I am.
Yes, well, the
world is changing.
And so it's so important
for us to be accepting.
We look at our country.
And it's really important
for us to understand
that the landscape and the
demographics of our country--
it's shifting.
And it's important that
we accept that and that we
understand that, at
the end of the day,
everyone in this
country is an immigrant.
Everyone comes from
that background.
And that we need to
not hold on to power,
but we need to open the
door for others, just
as others have opened the
door for us when we came.
And that's the challenge
we're experiencing now
in our country, that
there are so many who
are fearful of the change,
the changing demographics,
and want things to
remain the same.
But they're not going
to remain the same.
The numbers are changing.
And so it is best for us
to look at the advantages
that diversity brings,
as opposed to fear it,
look at the advantages of
what different cultures bring
to this country.
It's who we are.
And not fear the change that
is coming and understand
that if we continue to
resist, the rest of the world
is going to pass us by.
And so it's so important that
we focus on the best side of us
and not our fears.
AUDIENCE: So I'm recently--
I live in the city
of Boston, and I'm
in the process of enrolling
my kids into a school system.
And what I noticed was I
was attending a few sessions
on various programs, but
Boston public schools
have a high school
graduation rate in the 60s.
And so you take a look around at
the Boston public school system
and it's largely a lot of--
I know you don't like
the word minorities,
a lot of people
of color that have
no other option but
the public school
system, which I think a lot of
people agree is largely broken.
And I think in order
for people of color
to have the same opportunities
to get into companies that--
like Google or like
the banks you're
talking about that have
all these resources,
they need to be exposed to kind
of that environment and that,
as a path for when
they grow up, this
is what you can
have a career in.
And I feel like, if we have
something like a 60% graduation
rate in the Boston
public schools,
it just doesn't seem like--
there's no funnel of talent,
at least in the city of Boston.
And so I guess I was wondering
if you had any thoughts of--
I know a lot of your work
has been with companies,
but how can we, as a larger
company in Boston area,
how can we help improve that
high school graduation rate?
CAROL FULP: Well, first
of all, as you know,
this is the educational
mecca of the world.
And so there should be no reason
why we should have that rate.
But what we need to
do as corporations
is to partner with our
public school systems,
partner with our
city halls to help
address the issues, to help.
Because this is our
future workforce.
So we were just at
Biogen the other day
and they have this
wonderful community lab,
where they have
students coming in
and they're teaching
students science.
But this is a real opportunity
to take students and bring them
into companies, so that
they can learn and can see
that they can work here, too.
There are a number of
different programs,
but I do believe
each company should
be engaged in the community
and have programs connected
to the public school
system, because that just
makes good business sense.
So whether it's adopt a
school, or whether it's
going across industry and
teaching across the school
system.
But we need to realize
this is our future.
And we won't succeed
as a business community
with an uneducated workforce
in our public system.
SPEAKER 1: So I know
that a lot of times,
when people are going
into some of the biggest,
most celebratory moments, or
moments that become ones that
they're most proud of-- for
me, I'm reflecting on your time
at the UN General Assembly--
those are preceded
by things that
maybe are a little
more challenging
or you don't know
that that's coming
and you can be kind of
going through a time
of either complacency on
what you've been doing,
or trying to switch
gears or change gears.
And I know, as folks trying to
move through corporate America,
folks can be in jobs for a
while and then getting antsy
for that next big thing or that
next large opportunity that
could be coming.
And your career has been full
of very large opportunities
and really amazing work.
Has there ever been a time when
you were going into something
and you didn't
necessarily see your way
or weren't aware that that
next big thing was coming?
And how did you navigate
that stage before the time
where you were moving
to the next big thing?
CAROL FULP: You always
create opportunities.
You never wait for anything.
You put yourself in creative
environments, like this.
You always think of ways to open
doors for the next generation.
You come up with creative
ideas to bring along others.
I'm so cognizant that so
many people fought and died
and sacrificed so that
I could be sitting here,
so that you could
be sitting there.
So my job is so small
compared to what
others have done for me, so
there is always work to do.
And we all have a
responsibility to develop
the next generation of leaders.
And that requires a lot
of work, whether it's
the Boston public
school system, which
is something you're
focusing on, or whether it's
developing leaders
at our C-suite level
in the partnership.
But you never wait for anything.
You are always focused on
building and developing,
because others
fought and died so
that we could be sitting here.
And we have a job to do.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
all for your time.
And thank you, again.
CAROL FULP: Thank you.
Thank you.